this week the Trump administration
unveiled updated safety guidelines for
self-driving cars aimed at getting more
test vehicles on the road Transportation
Secretary Elaine Chao traveled to the
University of Michigan to make the
announcement the University is a vital
research facility where autonomous cars
already have the run of the road because
a town where they travel was built just
for them Michelle Miller has the story
call it any town USA a test track that
mimics every detail of our
transportation world chock-full of
highways byways railroad crossings and
bus stops so how is in city different
from your average test track great
question so M city itself isn't really
different than the real world and that's
in and of itself what makes it different
we carry Morton is the deputy director
of M city along with lab director Greg
Maguire we toured the ultimate learning
curve for driverless car research a
typical test track you're testing for
the performance of an individual vehicle
we can look at how these vehicles
operate together as part of a system not
only with each other but with the
infrastructure around them so you need
this simulated world in order to do it
the right way
that's right M city sits on 16 acres of
the University of Michigan campus and
offers just about every conceivable
driving conditions so right now we're in
the urban side of M city that allows us
to study your typical downtown urban
environment so we have parking meters
you know angle parking parallel parking
seven different types of traffic light
so now we're entering the high-speed
side which simulates highway operation
so we can study here vehicles entering
and exiting the highway lane change
manoeuvres M cities partners all have a
stake in the future of autonomous
driving from Intel to State Farm to the
Ford Motor Company which tests its cars
at M city here we have lots of different
pedestrian crossings in EM City so we
can see how pedestrians interact with
these vehicles
how are you essentially testing these
vehicles out here let's go through the
different scenarios sure so we hit one
right over here yeah we just went
through a roundabout so that's a perfect
scenario where we can study
interoperability so how are these
vehicles going to coexist on the road
together we can also study scenarios
where the automated vehicle can leverage
connectivity here we go we found out
what that means from debbie buzina of
the University of Michigan's
Transportation Research Institute
rolling down the highway
we're rolling down the highway someone
ahead of us does a heartbreaking event
break hard break yeah she broke hard
enough my system heard it told me I need
to stop okay
it was a test a vehicle to vehicle
communication
let's do forward collision you get a
little you get a little tingling in this
demo a car driving on a highway
unexpectedly slows down while traveling
around 35 miles an hour slow break okay
thank God
[Music]
the National Highway Traffic Safety
Administration says communication
technology shows great promise in
transforming the way Americans travel
saying it can save lives prevent
injuries East traffic congestion and
improve the environment
it says the technology can help cars see
around corners and through other cars in
April Nitsa closed a public commenting
period on a proposal to mandate the
technology for light cars and trucks
it's hoping to give the green light in
2019 it's not just the cars that will be
connected you see the two RS use
roadside units or RS use are also about
to communicate with vehicles so they're
broadcasting that there's ice on the
road ahead the RSU is broadcasting
information to my vehicle my vehicle
reacts to it
I see road ahead with rsu's able to
transmit at least a thousand feet away
buzina says it could prevent winter pile
ups like this something that would not
be possible for autonomous vehicles
right now with a sensor based system you
do have issues with snow rain fog but
with a communication based system that
doesn't come into play and that she says
will get autonomous vehicles on the road
faster this 15 C driverless shuttle will
be transporting students on the
University of Michigan campus this fall
for CBS this morning Saturday Michelle
Miller Ann Arbor Michigan
you know I'm every time I see something
like this I'm struck by you know how
futuristic it looks yet I know within
about 10 years this is gonna look quaint
yeah and I think Michelle's facial
expressions point of please I hope it's
stopping psychologically we're gonna all
have a hard time giving up the steering
wheel but we're gonna have to shout out
to my alma mater by the way where that's
taken lead